when we all saw grindhouse we saw fake
trailer for a movie called machete and
we all stood up and said in unison that
should be a real movie what do you know
dreams do come true
[Music]
[ __ ]
now machete is some good old-fashioned
Mexican starring the baddest ass looking
hombre if there is ever a guy who looks
like he has actually ended lives in real
life it's Danny Trejo
he's been double-crossed and left for
dead now he's gonna take out the people
who tried to screw him over make sense
who wouldn't and of course you got to
throw in those real world controversial
issues in this case it's illegal alien
something tells me the Arizona jokes are
just getting started now I absolutely
loved the first five minutes of this
movie had that shitty grindhouse look
and feel you know with the fake film
scratches on it like grindhouse had and
I won't lie I was absolutely hoping that
machete would have that and it did for
the first five minutes after the first
five minutes was over they went away but
don't get me wrong the movie still does
its job really really well I just wanted
my shitty grindhouse scratches I mean
had too much to ask and throughout his
quest machete gets a couple of friends
like Michelle Rodriguez and Jessica Alba
which I'm not gonna lie I'm gonna go
ahead and call [ __ ] on the Jessica
Alba romance thing generally speaking
Danny Trejo looks kind of like Marmaduke
after a seven-year meth binge in the
State Penitentiary Jessica Alba might
just be out of that ballpark but screw
it is machete you cannot take this movie
too seriously if you remotely take this
movie seriously Danny Trejo is gonna
jump out of the screen and personally
slap you which is really funny coming
from the guy who hated piranha 3d
machete just did the exploitation better
because in this world at least scary
badass Mexican Basterds Trump fish
everytime Cheech Marin is in it who
plays a priest with guns which I'm not
gonna lie makes for a pretty sweet scene
and the baddies include Robert De Niro
as the state senator Frank Lapidus from
lost who plays what does he play a rich
guy did he plays rich guy but the rich
guy who screwed over machete big mistake
and Aikido master and sheriff Stevens
the gulls in it which does he play it
does he play a Mexican in this movie I
don't know if he plays a Mac is he
supposed to play a Mexican that would be
weird and yes we cannot forget Lindsay
Lohan Lindsay Lohan is in this movie
sorta she plays a coked-out [ __ ] who
runs a porn website whose half
unconscious for the entire movie what
range she has in her acting ability she
probably didn't
she was being filmed at all it's just
all from hidden cameras in her house and
they just spliced the footage in so all
in all machetes a lot of fun it does
feel a little long for some odd reason
but I mean for the most part it's
exactly what you wanted machete to be so
I would say it's a good time no alcohol
required but if you do happen to get a
hold of alcohol or probably add to the
experience in a very good way yeah and
now it's a party and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more than click right here to see
more
[Music]